everything you want you can have
instantaneously everything you want
instant gratification accept job
satisfaction and strength of
relationships there ain't no app for
that they are slow Meandering
uncomfortable messy processes you have
an entire generation that's growing up
with lower self-esteem than previous
generations the other problem to
compound it is we're growing up in a
Facebook Instagram World in other words
we're good at putting filters on things
we're good at showing people that life
is amazing even though I'm depressed and
so everybody sounds tough and everybody
sounds like they got it all figured out
and the reality is there's very little
toughness and most people don't have it
figured out